lui % des voix ce n'est pas ce que dit
le ministère de l'intérieur il vous
donne 25 66% des bois et vous fait donc
passer derrière ensemble alors on a déjà
entendu un certain dans votre camp parlé
de manipulation à ce que tout simplement
vous n'avez pas parlé trop vite non je
pense que l'expérience des derniers mois
a montré à quel point le ministère de
l'intérieur était très fébrile avec
d'abord la nomination de notre alliance
il a fallu aller devant le conseil
d'état tout de même qui a intimé au
ministère de reconnaître notre nouvelle
union populaire la nuit baisse donc on a
là encore une stratégie politicienne de
très belles
fêtes stratégie c'est un choix c'est un
choix politique de du ministère de
l'intérieur il en est en charge et le
ministère de l'intérieur 1 il vous dit
au contraire que vous n'aviez investi
personnes en outre-mer que vous
revendiquez aujourd'hui des candidats en
métropole que vous n'aviez dans
télévision c'est ça la corne concernant
des pères oui mais l'accord ne
concernait pas l'outre-mer l'accord de
l'anhui mais ce sont des candidats et
comme date que nous soutenons
officiellement oui mais c'est vrai que
tarik nom et qui s'en revendiquent je
pense que karine le bon par exemple qui
est au premier tour qui est au second
tour et qu'il a dit a interpellé le
ministère en demandant à être comptés
comme les sommes comme
de la nouvelle union populaire donc
effectivement cet accord ne concerne
mais nous les soutenons officiellement
et quand on voit par exemple la manière
dont le ministère de l'intérieur a
inscrit des députés d'outre-mer comme
étant des soutiens ou alors même des
dissidents mais ne fait pas la même pour
nous on voit bien qu'il ya une tactique
ne me livre interior par exemple des
milices pas mais la bad comme candidats
ensemble ni marie luce penchard qui
pourtant est elle même soutenue par la
majorité présidentielle voyez donc no
idea c'est un choix politique donc ça
n'a rien à remédier à des critères
objectifs mais dont vous parlez vous
parler de manipulation vous entendez que
évidemment ils peuvent ou désavantagé
mais là ils viennent ça concerne aussi
désormais ma question mais c'est le
choix qui est fait griller ce qui fait
le choix c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur des déclarations qui sont
faites pour elle a brillé qui est à la
tête de du ministère de l'intérieur
monsieur darmana qui a déjà été pris la
main dans le sac par le conseil d'état
donc oui c'est une route du col ère
politique ou de policiers a de nouveau
requis voix nous y réfléchissons on
verra s'il est besoin et s'il est
nécessaire de le faire et si je me
rappelle bien que les annulations à ça
ma question pas si parce qu'on a plein
de questions vous posez daniel jaunas
parce que vous êtes maintenant tu
vraiment au coeur du sujet mais s'il ya
une manipulation ce que vous dites ce
que jean luc mélenchon a laissé entendre
ce matin fait il a dit non et pas mais
une population dense a quand même vous
allez vous allez au conseil d'état c'est
évident si vous n'allez pas vous êtes
assez vous mais pas sur quelle
manipulation nous allons des
sous-entendus nous allons étudier la
question comme nous l'avions fait
précédemment en vérifiant exactement
quels critères a choisi et quels sont
les justifications données bailleur
parole le ministère et on fera les
démarches qu'il faut mais on voyait pas
sur qui un salaire mais si il ya un
problème alors mené aux côtés et
pourtant nous prenons le temps de faire
les choses sérieusement parce que c'est
une question sérieuse si nous avons
interpellé c'est que nous considérons
effectivement que en reprenant
politiquement les choix qui sont faits
par une nouvelle union populaire de
soutien nous arrivons en tête et ce
n'est pas anodin effectivement que le
ministère de l'intérieur monsieur
darmanin veuille nous faire apparaître
comme second donc nous ferons les
démarches que nous estimons nécessaire
on tend vers regardera ce l'âme on va
essayer de se projeter vers le second
tour où se trouve aujourd'hui vos
réserves de voix mais comme je les dis
alors d'abord c'est pas c'est pas un
réservoir qui sur lesquels
les documents nous on s'adresse d'abord
à l'ensemble de la population et de tous
les électeurs et les électrices il faut
il s'agit de s'assurer que celles et
ceux qui sont déjà allés voter
reviennent ce dimanche et puis bien
entendu toutes celles des millions de
français et françaises qui se sont ne se
sont pas rendus aux urnes donc notamment
dans la jeunesse
oui et ça toujours été d'ailleurs notre
stratégie y compris à la présidentielle
où nous avions vu dans de nombreux
quartiers populaires des primo votants
et vos tentes qui sont venus parce que
nous avions fait ce travail assez léché
et donc là c'est l'échec quand même
lorsque vous voyez l'abstention louis
alors les bureaux version mais c'est un
échec collectif moi je vous rappelle
tout de même que jusqu'à 2016 aussi le
vôtre non non attendez non non il ya des
responsabilités quand même au niveau de
l'état jusqu'à 2016 l'état mener des
campagnes pour rappeler les campagnes
nationales avec des spots publicitaires
avec de l'incitation en formule 1
aujourd'hui il n'en fait plus neal a
choisi de ne plus en faire donc c'est
une première responsabilité et après
nous nous avons fait notre travail nous
avons médité sur le terrain nous avons
fait des caravanes pour la réinscription
sur les listes électorales et à notre
niveau nous n'avons pas les moyens de
l'état encore une fois monsieur darmanin
la devrait peut-être répondre à quelques
questions à ce niveau là et puis bien
sûr l'abstention tarn à neuf normales
responsable on voit la manière dont il
gère tout cela de du stade de france
jusqu'aux élections avait compris les
questions on attend sioniste
[Musique]